a common question among ceos
entrepreneurs of a small business is pat
how do i keep strong talent with me why
do i lose
some of my best people that leave me so
today we're going to talk about
20 reasons why you keep losing good
[Music]
talent
so look this doesn't just apply to
employees this could be sales people you
could be running a real estate office
you got 20 realtors working for you but
you keep losing your
number one producer your number not
number nine number number 17
you're number one number two why do you
keep losing that or
pharmaceutical sales insurance financial
it doesn't matter if you keep losing
your best talent
you have to know that there's something
there let me make point number one i got
19 more to go after this number one is
safety
what is safety safety is a boring word
nothing about safety gets a person to
say oh my gosh i had an epiphany moment
but the reason why some of the greatest
leaders don't
lose people it's them they're like man i
hope he never fires me i really want to
work for this guy
is because they bring an element of
safety in their environment i don't mean
by bulletproof windows i don't mean by
you know their hurricane proof or
earthquake proof their safety date
you're reliable
you're predictable you're somebody
that's extremely consistent
you know i'm gonna get called out if i
do xyz but i know
i'm gonna get recognition if i do this i
know if i do
this this above everybody else i'm gonna
get promoted it's a very
safe environment and i know what to
expect from you because you provide
safety
to me number two that's also potentially
boring but it's why people quit on you
is character lack of character this last
week i was in louisville giving a speech
and i we had a 1500 of our guys there at
this event
tebow was a bunch of people that were
there i asked the guy's question i said
when you hire somebody
what is the number one quality you look
for uh it's competitiveness this talent
all the stuff we heard right i said
there's nothing more important than
character
to lock on to someone now what is
character to me characters are many
different things but
if you tell me you're going to do
something you do it 80 90 percent of the
time
you have a score on character no one is
no one has 100 like a computer memory
alert reminds you right
but the scores got to be 80 to 90 now
imagine the people that you tell them to
do something and they only remember 10
of their time it's part of character
they're going to do that in everything
they do right so
if i got a guy that's leading the team
if i say here's what we need from you
they do it
same thing if you i work for you
if you tell me if you do this this is
you're going to get this but you forget
or you don't keep your word or the bonus
or the raise
or the integrity or the trustworthy or
no clear set of values and principles
and it's a lack of inconsistency in
their
and i notice a a
a flaw in the character that's
consistent regularly
you don't make me feel what point number
one save
if you don't make me feel safe then i
have to go to a different
place to feel safe the reason why people
left iran is because they didn't feel
safe for their family there so we went
to germany then we come here the reason
why people escape mexico to come here
the reason why people leave companies to
go elsewhere is because the long term
they say i don't feel
safe here i want to go somewhere else to
feel safe with myself because i
trust the character over here i know
it's boring stuff but i tell you this
the valuable stuff on why you
end up keeping the best people around
you number three is not showing up they
just don't see you you're not there
you're inconsistent you're there one day
you're not the next day you're golfing
you're kicking back you're always
traveling you're not accessible
not showing up is another reason why
people end up quitting on you number
four
lack of enthusiasm you're not excited
it's just kind of like going to work and
you're boring it's like it's the same
thing you're doing over and over again
if you're the boss if you're the leader
if you're the guy that's running the
department the gal that's running the
department
the entrepreneur the founder the ceo and
you lack enthusiasm
what the hell am i coming to work for
your enthusiasm gives me enthusiasm it
shouldn't be the other way around
your team doesn't give you enthusiasm
the leader gives everybody enthusiasm so
if i'm working with somebody
that's fired up oh my gosh i can't wait
to go to work for this guy right
but if i'm working for somebody hey uh
everything good you guys you guys good
okay
all right good there's gotta be
enthusiasm so you gotta sometimes
respect your enthusiasm number five is
flip-flopping you change your mind often
it's constantly changing your mind first
you know i had to do this to get
recognized now you got to do this then
it's going
this no we're going to do this then
we're going to change your philosophy
you know we're going to so we're 60
about finish this project no let this
one go go over here you change your mind
so often that people like
i don't even know what to do anymore
here you indirectly actually stop people
from focusing on their project
because you're always changing your mind
non-stop
so the more clear you get about what
you're doing this doesn't mean we don't
have
audits audibles and pivots and all that
other stuff
but there's got to be a consistent
direction that we're going as a company
where you're not constantly
flip-flopping next one fake unauthentic
you ever met people that are fake how
long does it take to find out someone's
fake sometimes people can't fake it for
a day
for a week for a month for three months
you can't typically fake it for six
months what happens eventually when you
realize someone is fake
we don't like to work with fake people
you decide to say i can't be at a place
like this
i want to work with somebody that's real
you can't be fake visionary
you either do have a vision or you don't
have a vision you can be a fake big
thinker because you saw a video you got
excited so he said the same thing
that that guy said in the video now
you're a big thinker you're not a big
thinker
you're a good parent copycatting
somebody else's message
but are you a big thinker if you're not
eventually people are going to know
you're not
so they're going to say this guy keeps
talking about we're going to take over
the world but he shows up late he's
never here never works
always sleeps and he's kicking back and
he's my boss he's not as hungry i don't
know what the hell i'm doing here this
guy's fake
he's not a visionary that's eventually
going to be revealed by the way just so
you know that based on your
results so another reason why people
quit on some leaders out the next one
lack of putting in effort into the
relationship meaning
if this person has a direct report to
you build a relationship with them
how's the family how are things how you
doing everything good how was your
weekend you guys go out did you do them
relationship building you got to put
into the relationship where the person
says this isn't just business
this guy actually cares about the
relationship as well that that little
additional push into the relationship
gets people to say
if i was normally working and giving
this guy seven i'm giving this sign
nine if i was normally working and i
can't wait to book it and get out of
here because this guy doesn't know who i
am he doesn't care about me
459 i'm willing to work till 6 30. i
choose to stay till 6 30.
so you keep the best people around you
you choose whether you want them with
your long-term or not
not them because they love working for
you because you're a great leader the
next reason why people quit on is
because you've been the same for years
you're the same as you were three years
ago you were five years ago you're not a
new person so imagine i'm working for
you
and i went from a five to seven but
you've been a seven and a half for the
last three years
so i'm doing my part but you're right
here if i don't see you constantly
recreate yourself and improve i'm gonna
go find somebody else that's recreating
themselves
and improving that's how the game works
okay
you ever been you ever met somebody a
boyfriend girlfriend they're dating each
other for your two years and i was like
i just can't why
this guy's just the same it's just got
no aspirations not improving out any
eventually if you don't constantly
recreate yourself people will go find
somebody else that
is recreating themselves number nine
arrogance
so let's just say your business starts
getting bigger you make more money
you're becoming more popular
you're now rich you now have a million
10 million 100 million dollars in a bank
you start becoming arrogant nobody wants
to be around somebody else that sucks
all the energy and
everything is about you if you do that
people cannot coexist in an environment
like this especially high identity
people
high identity people are typically also
confident they also want recognition
and if it's all about you two people
like that cannot co-exist your talented
people are gonna leave because it has to
be about them not you
so if you're a king not a king maker all
the potential future kings that were
working with you
will leave look at amazon right now
they're introducing who has their new
ceo andy right
that's what you call a king maker
microsoft king maker
you know all these inver tim tim cook is
a king maker after jobs you understand
everything is about
being able to give other guys the
opportunity one to become king maker if
it's all about you
you become arrogant you will lose your
best talent in no time
next you no longer compete your team has
to see you competing
it doesn't matter what you're doing you
have to say look we're going to be the
best
real estate office in the following
three zip codes period we're going to do
that
awesome let's go we're going to be the
best person great we're going to be the
best
digital advertising company for the
industry of this this this
awesome i love when he says that and
then you go compete for your market
share
there's something very attractive about
the leader at the top competing
wanting more market share it gets your
team wanted to come in sports team
people love playing for kobe because he
was competing constantly
people love playing with jordan because
this guy was competing they they
didn't like how much of a driver they
were but they forgave because they
wanted to win
so bad they were such great competitors
it's
attractive to keep your best talent if
you're competitive not combative
but competitive next is you no longer
make that additional call now what is
that additional call mean here's what
the additional call is
say you had a you know meeting today and
you call that one your employees
and it was pretty heated meeting you
drive home you're like forget about it
you come up to work the next day regular
day rather
you make the phone call saying hey i
want you to know today even though i
called you out and chewed you out i just
want you to know i still believe in you
and i think if you fix this this this
you can be this okay
but can we make sure this doesn't happen
again because the second time
no you got it pat i'm gonna work on it
okay awesome have a great day buddy i'll
see you in the morning
it's a two minute call it's not a 30
minute call it's a
two-minute call to make that increases
retention
i can't even put a number on it's not a
small percentage
it's a massive percentage those that
make that additional call
end up retaining better talent those
that don't have the time to make and
they're doing other things
lose those few people and they wonder i
don't know why i lost this person
you don't make that additional call
let's continue next one
is you say your c suite executive say
you're a founder so you're making a
quarter million
so you're making a half a million say
making a million same thing 10 million a
year
you're like 10 an hour people oh 15 an
hour people
you're not at i don't have time for you
if you no longer
can talk to somebody that's making 15 an
hour 20 bucks an hour 30 grand you're 40
50 grand year because you're just too
much for them
you're about to lose your votes you need
everybody
lincoln used to say what made a great
general and a president is
go circulate amongst the troops troops
are not
generals troops are not president but
they are the troops and they are
very very important even if you go then
say how are you doing john house things
how's everything here you doing good
versus hey do you know who i am
do you know who i am no go circulate
amongst your troops and be able to
relate to the 15
an hour person because at one point that
was you working for minimum wage at 14
15 16 20 years or whatever it was
so make sure you relate and are able to
connect with the people that are not the
highest earners with your company
number 13 poor handling of your finances
if you don't manage your finances well
and you're always panicking you're
people going to feel it
you know when your mom and dad were
struggling financially did you not feel
it like you were a kid how did you feel
it i felt it when my parents were broke
financially they were arguing they never
told me we're broke but i felt the
energy was so
obvious i was seven years old i could
feel it if you're a boss supervisor ceo
your finances are not in order i
guarantee you everyone around you feels
it
get your finances in order cash in the
bank produces the kind of confidence
that others will feel
and it takes a lot of pressure off but
if you don't have your finances in order
people like oh my gosh i better get out
here before it loses everything
it's hard to be around him because i
feel like i'm walking on eggs he's so
much under stress he's always
very obvious why people quit so make you
make sure your finances are in order the
next one
you've lost respect for the game what
does that mean you're just kind of
entitled you just kind of show up it's
just
regular the moment you lose respect for
the game you lose people the moment you
lose respect for
what it requires to be able to compete
at the highest level like you used to
you no longer do you lose people it's
that simple you can never
if you're ever in the arena competing
you can never lose respect for the game
the game is very very demanding i'm not
a lebron james fan
you know how much i respect the fact
that he keeps his body in shape the way
he does because he
respects the game that's why
people who even don't like him they
respect the game because they respect
lebron because he respects the game the
same applies to you
when you're running your business if you
don't people will feel it next you
gradually lower your standards you're
gradually i don't know if this is
important ah it's okay
don't worry about it's okay ah it's okay
some of the best of the people you're
gonna have in your in your team that are
working with you
the highest the best ones are gonna be
like why is this guy keep lowering
standards i gotta work with somebody
who's got higher standards i'm gonna go
do my own thing
the moment you lower your standards and
flinch there's other people that are not
and you will lose market share so again
if you're in the arena
there's some people may be like pat this
is so overwhelming this is too much
pressure
why would i want to do it this way
that's if you want to be in the arena
let me continue
number 16 how you handle conflict do you
always fight
do you flight do you freeze how do you
handle conflict
do you handle it properly or do you
process say what happened today can we
talk about it let's process it
your method of handling conflict could
be a reason why people quit
or stick around long term with you so
maybe you ought to improve in the way
you handle conflict next one you give
outsiders too much influence over your
organization meaning
you bring in speakers you bring in
outsiders you bring in all these folks
that are here and
they got more influence over your
organization than you do and then all of
us are like why do i lose that person
because
you've lost influence with your team you
have to have influence over your team
i i can have outsiders with my kid but
if at the end of the night i don't go
home and i said so how was your day
today what happened today tell me about
the teacher tell me about the student
what happened
okay what was that all about why did
that take place okay you're not you
still have a little bit of influence not
control
but influence the moment you lose
influence and it's all outside they're
gonna eventually leave you
and go outside you can't give up that
influence too early
and not only too early you gotta have
some kind of an influence over your
organization next
you stop being an example now you're
only telling people what to do versus
leading them don't get me wrong there's
a
lot of value to being a good manager
lots of value into being a great manager
but leading is the example you know if
if you have the example of what you've
done and you give that to them people
like that people like the fact that
there is an example
that's being done so you got to
continuously put up your example or else
they're going to go find somebody else
who is setting the example now you may
say but pam i set the example 20 years
ago
i set the example 10 years ago it
doesn't matter if you want the best of
me today
i need your best example today 19.
you no longer cast division you forgot
to cast a vision it's no longer one day
we will imagine if what if
can you think about if one day we do
you're no longer casting vision because
you're no longer thinking about division
your stomach is full
you lose people if you're still casting
a vision like you can't even help
yourself
they buy it they want to be with you
because they're excited they're going
somewhere big
with you but they start stop casting a
vision they leave you to somebody else
and last but not least you forgot what
the number one product was in business
the number one product in business is in
real estate not property not insurance
not technology not software not any of
this if your number one product
in business is people you cannot forget
that your number one most
important product in business is people
you forget that you will lose your
people
you never forget that you will not lose
your people and eventually you get to
choose to
attract and keep the best people
and they will leave you when you say
this just didn't work out i wish you the
best go elsewhere and they'll say
my best experience on when i grew was
when i worked with
you that guy was high standards he's the
reason why i'm doing so good today
because i work with that guy
for nine years i work with her for 17
years i work with
people give that credit back players who
were on john would no john wouldn't
change my life phil jackson changed my
life that ought to change my life
because it was that example in their
life so imagine if you become that
to other people having said that if
you're watching this video and you're
still with us
if you enjoyed it press the thumbs up
button and share it with someone if you
think there's value in this
if you want to get another video that
has to do with those topics a video i
did called
uh eight ways how to hold people account
i think it's eight or ten ways to hold
people accountable if you've never seen
a click over here to watch it
it's very detailed it's how i do it it's
some of the philosophy side doing and i
think you'll get a lot of value from it
take care everybody bye